[Music]
what are the most important next steps
from
from your perspective with respect to
even thinking about regulation the best
questions to ask or just concrete steps
well i always like to use self-driving
cars because everyone can relate to this
so
in california there's a concept called a
rolling stop
the california roll yes
and and when you come to the stop sign
you sort of forget to fully stop you
roll through so the police car
policeman comes over and says you did
the rolling stop and i say to the
policeman
sir i did not
and then it said who did and it's and
then the car says i did sir
and the policeman says why and the car
says i don't know
very frustrating for the police officer
yeah so
who gets the ticket
so your choices are the human
the car itself the manufacturer of the
car
or the data that the car was trained
with
right so that's the debate to have
give you another example
i feel very strongly in favor of free
speech for humans
but i don't feel very strongly for
amplification by computers
and so what we're seeing now is we're
seeing humans who have wacky
wacky false conspiratorial ideas what
have you
get picked up and amplified in these
systems
that drives everyone crazy because we
can't tell the difference between a
genuine social movement and concern
versus a single crazy person who has an
amplified idea that seems plausible but
is basically false we have no way of
falsifying such things
that's something that's got to get
sorted out
we can't live in an information space
that is so full of misinformation
and manipulation that we can't get
through the day
when we go back in the book to talk
about the renaissance we say this is a
new epoch
because in addition to this
misinformation that we've been speaking
about
we also have never had a situation
in our human experience where there was
an intelligence that was similar to ours
but not the same that was non-human
and so imagine a situation where these
intelligences exist
and they can be consulted
well who gets to consult them what
happens to their answers
so for example if it's an oracle do you
have a rule that every answer from the
oracle is published to the world
because it's presumably beneficial but
what if it's a private question or a
secret what if it's being used in
national security again these are
questions that we have not resolved so
what we say is these are really hard
questions
what happens when the ai perceives
aspects of reality that humans do not
that it sees a connection there are
physicists who talk about new universes
and new worlds
and you can imagine a situation where
there is some thing that we as humans
cannot conceive of
because of our limited intelligence but
the computer detects it and then we say
oh my god
in math there's a
a long story about
an object that lives in a
two-dimensional world
and the third dimension appears but if
you're in a two-dimensional world that
you don't you never see the third
dimension so you're always confused
so what if this ai can find a
dimensionality of the world that we as
humans not a single one of us can
understand
and we're now confused
we don't know how to handle that
what what happens another example is
dr kissinger believes
that
i'll paraphrase
when something is not understandable by
humans
they will perceive it as an act of god
or they will resist it
and you can imagine a situation where
you end up with nativists
who decide that this world that i'm
describing is so impossibly unpleasant
that they turn it all off and they go to
the equivalent of
the woods of pennsylvania and they say
leave me alone
and you have other people who learn to
drive it and manipulate it for good and
evil
that you'll you'll have a choice and
then one final scenario to think about
goes like this
let's say you're older um the kids are
grown
and it's time for you to
to take a break from the world so you
put on headphones
and vr glasses
and in those vr glasses and headphones
you have a life of you as a much younger
person
a much more beautiful handsome wealthier
stronger whatever
with the friends that you remember of
the time recreated even though they may
have passed away
that might be a more fun life for you
every day
than the life that you have in this
scenario
what happens when we lose people i call
that crossing to the other side
when they wake up in the morning they
just want to be over there
that will happen too
you